let's go to Tim from Binghamton Tim
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
can you hear me okay I can hear you fine
awesome so I'm a teacher I've uh called
in before a long time listener I think
you're one of the best voices on the
left thank you for everything that you
do
um and I just want to talk about an
epidemic happening in our schools
um I've been teaching for six years now
and I've watched the progression of the
addiction to cell phones with kids reach
a remarkable level it is something that
you know we ask them as teachers we
don't have a universal policy but we ask
them hey put these phones in a bucket
during obstruction time and we're gonna
try to get you focused and they cling on
to them almost like heroin addicts yeah
and I I just don't know
um if there's enough national attention
around how we are bringing these kids up
with these devices
um and I just I want to know your
thoughts on how we might approach this
as a national discussion I'm basically
with you as to the level of problem that
this is I think it really is an epidemic
I think there's a couple different
things here this is a separate issue
from adult so-called addiction to social
media specifically I think there's two
different things and we want to make
sure we deal with them differently what
you're talking about uh I I see it
firsthand and a lot of my friends who
have kids and from those who teach in
schools I also hear it and there clearly
is something physical that goes on with
these screens even like with my baby
daughter who's not even six months old
sometimes like if she's just handed to
me for for two minutes and I'm sitting
at my desk even if I face her completely
away from the screens she starts craning
her neck trying to get a look at the
screens and we don't show her any screen
so I just basically walk out of the room
um it does seem that
there is something just physical going
on here and my concern is attention
spans inability to focus inability to do
what Cal Newport calls deep work so at
the societal level or at schools I have
no idea what the solution should be I
know I'm going to take a personal
approach you know and for now it's
basically no screens period and we'll
revisit it at some future period you
know Future Point uh but no I agree with
you it's an absolute epidemic
yeah one last Quick point I did work at
a charter school for a brief amount of
time where they took the phones at the
door yes um and that had a huge uh
impact on teaching and learning it was
incredibly powerful I just don't know if
public schools have the resources they
need
um to I mean it'll take an army to get
the phones at the door and it's gonna be
a battle and it's and it's something
that the parents aren't all on board
with because they text their kids in
school it's an absolute nightmare that's
what I wanted to do which is I've I've
know people who teach at Charter Schools
who have had good luck with that they
even have these devices that like you
hold the phone but the phone is in a
device I forget what the name of it is
you just can't use it until the end of
the day but that there is that issue
where for for many kids parents are
relying on that in case they need to
communicate anything in case there's an
emergency or whatever I don't know how
frequent that is I don't know how good
of an argument that is but I think even
parents nonsense it's nonsense you say
yeah it's nonsense it is so
um anyway I'll let you get some more
calls uh you're awesome David keep up
the great work happy holidays and uh
enjoy the time with your family all
right thank you and likewise uh big big
time holiday coming up here in the
United States the science tells us that
one of the best ways to get consistent
deep sleep is lowering your core body
temperature when your body stays cooler
at night you're more comfortable and
your sleep is better our sponsor sleep
me is the home of chili sleep the
customizable climate controlled sleep
solutions that can improve your sleep by
keeping you cooler at night there are
three different chili sleep systems
there's the uler the cube and the new
Doc Pro with double the cooling power
all three systems are water-based
temperature controlled mattress toppers
that fit over your existing mattress to
provide you with your ideal sleep
temperature you can go as cool as 55
degrees you can go really hot if you
want I keep mine at 60 beautiful
temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night